I've been in business for 14 years. We spend
tens of millions of dollars per year in paid
advertising, and in this video I'm going to share
something I've never shared before - which is
that I have 12 internal hacks that we use
whenever we write any piece of advertising
or copy that goes out to sell stuff.
And I'm going to give you all of them.
So let's start with number one - Headlines
Come First for a reason and the reason I have
it as the first one is that it is the first
and most important so to quote David Oggovy
uh once you've written your headline you spent
80 cents of your advertising dollar right and so
that means that the vast majority of people will
only see the headlines in whatever it is that you
make and it almost feels unfair that a headline
is just a phrase or one word or one question but
it is also the thing that is ultimately going to
get the most people to or have the biggest lever
on whether your advertisements do well so think
about it like this because it's the law of small
numbers which is if you go from let's say a 1%
click-through rate to a 3% click-through rate you
triple the amount of of people who are ultimately
going to see everything else that you have and
so there's very little things that happen in the
rest of the entire funnel that have the ability to
triple sometimes you get 20% lift 50% lifts that'd
be a monster split test but a banger or killer
headline can absolutely outperform the control
by two three sometimes 5x right that is why it's
so important and it feels unfair because it's so
short but the thing is is the best advertisers the
more they've been doing it the more they obsess
on the hook they obsess on the headline because
they know that's where the money's at right like
if you have a winning hook for your ad campaigns
you keep using it to death and you try and beat
it and so here's the here's some of the things
that I write down which is curiosity is king
different is ideal and sexy works and never run
an ad without a headline because the thing is is
all ads have headlines there's just bad ones and
good ones because if you don't write a headline
you do have a headline it's just not very good
and so fundamentally the headlines serve to give
us a different wrapping paper for the same offers
and you want this headline to be so powerful and I
like this visual it grabs the reader by the throat
right and so bonus points is how can I know that
something's going to work ahead of time one of the
best ways to test headlines and hooks is to look
at your organic content or other people's organic
content or other people's ads look at the first 3
seconds visually and verbally what are they saying
and what's happening in the background and those
are the first places that I'm going to look in
order to model what headlines apply to me now
the the really sexy hack around this is can I
take can I steal like an artist from a different
industry can I look at ads that are working well
in the travel space and use them in business
can I look at ads in the weight loss space and
use them in business or whatever space you're
in and so some thoughts I have are curiosity
quotes questions are there kind of emotional
outcomes or experiences that I'm describing
one of my favorite headlines of all time is how
to yay without boo if you biggest insecurity
right i'll say that again how to yay good thing
without boo bad thing even if you biggest fear
how to speak confidently in front of strangers
without ever practicing even if you're deathly
afraid of speaking in public fyi there are entire
books written on each of these 12 pieces that I'm
going to talk about i'm trying to give you the
8020 because at the end of the day when you're
writing ads you're not going to read 12 books
before you write the ad you're going to have a
little mental checklist that you go over and
that's the checklist I'm giving you yeah and
so each of these bullets are kind of like the
best like best converting nuggets that I have
on each of these kind of mini topics and so this
is like my little cheat sheet so whenever I get
stuck or I need a new idea or for a new image or a
video or copy this is what I use to kind of remind
myself number two say what only you can say so if
you've done something remarkable or different you
want to say it proof will always outdo promise so
the reason at the very beginning of this video I
said we spent tens of millions of dollars on
ads last year between our portfolio companies
so this isn't like we don't have an agency that's
actually us spending money in our actual companies
um so it's not like me taking credit for all the
clients that I have uh like it's not that it's
like these are companies that I own that we spent
money on to generate revenue right so we risk real
money behind these things now if you're the only
triple black belt in your local area say so if
you're the only person who's helped moms over 35
who are vegan powerlifters say so if you're the
only person who like the thing is is that what you
want to do is you want to be one of a kind but the
beauty is that you get to control what the pond
that you're one of a kind is and so the friendly
reminder here is that competitors can copy your
offer but they cannot copy your proof that has
to be earned and so one of the big reasons the big
defenses that I believe exists for people who have
done stuff which is why you should do stuff is
that it doesn't matter how many AI avatars come
out the AI avatar can never have done something
in the real world they can lie but they can never
have done something and so no one can take your
story or your experiences away from you and this
is one of the things that excites me about the
future of AI is that story is still going to
be paramount why should I listen to you is still
going to be a question at the top of everyone's
mind and in a world where trust is going to get
diminished very rapidly where we're not going to
know what's real and what isn't verification of
facts is going to be even more important so say
what only you can say number three always call
out who you're looking for and bonus points who
you're not looking for which is actually even more
powerful than the original call out so because
it's one thing to say hey you know I'm looking
for business owners but if you say hey if you're
below $250,000 a year you're below $500,000 you're
below a million dollar a year hey this isn't for
you go consume my free content it it communicates
very strongly where you position yourself in the
marketplace and so if you only want to help people
who want to lose a lot of weight not a little bit
of weight like there's a big advantage you know
what's funny i've actually never seen anyone in
weight loss do this but just say like "Hey only
for people who are trying to look o lose over 30
lbs." Here's the crazy part there's enough people
who are trying to lose over 30 lbs that you can
say no to the people who have less than 30 lbs to
lose here's the other great thing about people who
have over 30 lbs to lose is that you might only
need a couple hundred customers in order to make
your business work and there's like a billion
people many billions but maybe only a billion
that speak your language doesn't matter point
is is that most people are afraid of saying no
to customers but when you say no to customers you
polarize the customers who are the right customer
to move even more towards you what you don't want
to be is vanilla if you say "I'm everything to all
people i accept all customers." Then it means no
one feels pulled to your marketing because they're
never going to think "Oh this is for me." That
is the result that we want to have happen from
our advertising that someone self- selects they
raise their hand and be like "Wow I feel like this
person's talking to me." And so when you advertise
you never advertise to the masses you advertise to
one person and so you want to be very clear when
you're writing your copy who is that one person
i want to identify the reader i want to identify
the viewer or the listener right and you want them
to think how does he know my secrets well you can
only be that specific if you're talking about one
person and so as you go through this you can go
through different levels of awareness which is
like at the top level someone can be completely
unaware so you have to hook them with curiosity
at a level underneath of that you have to have
someone who might be problem aware hey do you get
up at night to pee more than two times hey have
you ever had someone cancel a contract before it
comes due right these are problem aware then you
have solution aware which is like have you ever
tried to collect using some of these softwares and
it hasn't worked the way it was supposed to have
you ever tried a supplement and it hasn't gotten
the results that you want that's solution aware
right underneath of that you have product aware
okay have you ever tried this type of creatine
versus this type have you ever tried an ad agency
before that's done meta ads right these are very
very more aware customers and finally the most
aware customers are people who already know about
you and about your product and then you have to
make offers to those people but at all all the
way through the stack we want to talk to people as
though we know who they are because you probably
do and the crazy thing is that customers this is
the crazy part about customers we all you want
to lean into the fact that everyone is selfish
everyone thinks they're the center of their own
universe and when you can say something that
actually affects many many people but you can
say it as though they think that they're alone
in the universe when you are specific that is
what creates compelling copy specificity
and so if I say "Hey are you overweight?"
That's that's trit marketing you don't want to
use terms like marketing ease like like like um
marketing speak marketing lingo right you've read
ad copy before and been like "Oh this is ad copy."
The way that you get out of that is by taking
words that people use and breaking them down into
chunks and so by saying "Hey uh instead of saying
are you overweight?" It's do you have trouble
getting upstairs or going on a a walk for a long
period of time without a rash forming between your
legs and sweating in places you didn't know you
could when you say that that's much more specific
and so what we want to think about is what are the
moments that someone's going to experience fatness
what are the moments someone's going to experience
brokenness what are the moments someone's going to
experience frustration in their marriage or their
friendship or loneliness like we talk about the
moments because the moments is what they remember
no one remembers the vague words and that's not
what gets them to emote or have an emotion and
then ultimately lowers the actions threshold
so they take the next step and so for example I
just had a a cash episode with a gentleman who
does bar consulting so he helps bars become more
profitable uh like restaurant bars and so when I
looked at the copy it looked generic it looked
like he was just using marketing lingo rather
than saying "Hey when you look behind the bar does
it look like a bomb went off?" Right does it look
like this is a homeless shelter behind your bar
right the thing is is that you're probably going
to laugh but the person's probably like "Yeah my
bar looks like that it's a mess." Right and the
thing is is that that's a moment when they walk
in or they look behind the counter and they're
like "What happened?" That's the moment we want to
pinpoint because they probably had that happen the
last seven days and if that pain is is fresh
the likelihood that they then take that next
action is high so the next one is number four
always have a reason why and this is big so I
like to use the uh the fraternity party planner
uh perspective which is that it doesn't actually
matter what reason you use but more so that you
have a reason to begin with and so this uh the
first point when I started adding this in was um
I think I read one of Keini's things ages ago uh
where we talked about how when people were cutting
other people in line if they had a good reason
people were more likely to let them cut in which
is basically a persuasion win they said "Hey can
I get in line in front of you?" And he's like "Hey
I've got this paper I've got to turn in i need to
copy it quickly and so people said yes but later
they tested it where they just said "Hey I have
to get in line because my cat is back home." It
has nothing to do with getting in line or needing
urgency around the copy they just basically said
because insert random reason but having a reason
in general for most people makes it better than
no reason at all and so the word because is one
of the most influential words in the English
language use it because it works and so if you
are going to use a reason great now you get bonus
points for a reason if you can tie it back to
urgency or scarcity in some way which I'll talk
about those two in more depth later and so when
you're giving your reasons why what I encourage
you to focus on is giving them the reason why to
do the next step and just that right every line
of copy sells reading the next line of copy and
then those lines of copy sell the click and then
the click sells the and then the the landing page
that after comes from the click the headline of
that page sells the opt-in from the opt-in it
sells showing up to the next thing is that we just
want to be very clear about our messaging one step
at a time because someone can't take nine steps
we want to sell one step and be very clear about
what we want them to do next right a a confused
mind does not buy and a confused mind certainly
does not click and so when I say thinking about
this as a fraterning party planner is what reasons
does a fraterning party planner need in order to
plan a party not many at all the bar for having a
reason to party is quite low timmy got his wisdom
teeth out kegger you know so John broke up with
his girlfriend kegger uh it's Tuesday let's drink
right and so the idea is that you don't actually
have to have a reason that's good in your mind you
just need to have a reason in general it could be
your birthday it could have been your birthday
last month it could be your wife's birthday it
could be your dog's birthday right it could be
the anniversary of the business there's four
dates that you can run for a whole month right
it's my dad my dog's birth month this month and
for that reason we're running this offer right
it does not matter now how do we make it even
more compelling and this one's nasty this may be
if I had a favorite which is hard to say because
it's like picking between your kids um which of
course everybody has a favorite child um kidding
calm down anyways uh is damaging admissions all
right there is probably I mean in my experience
nothing more powerful than damaging admissions now
what's very interesting about this is they've done
research on basically the persuasiveness
of somebody who admits their bias upfront
so if you say "Hey I make money from these videos
in the following ways." People even though they
know that you admit you have a bias they are now
more likely to believe you because you said you
have a bias because you've actually been truthful
and so you want to own your flaws and damaging
admissions in my opinion are so powerful because
they're actually just rooted in truth so you want
to always own your flaws of course you have them
of course your product isn't perfect say so and
what you'll sacrifice in promise you'll gain in
trust and trust trumps promise think about the
promises that you have to give to a referral very
little why because you are borrowing the trust of
the introduction of the person so when you get a
referral you're like "Yeah uh you helped my friend
Sandy so I'll buy." You don't need to promise
much at all because they trust you and so I would
rather always sacrifice promise to gain trust and
so there's a you know the famous Eminem story of
uh he figured out when he was rapping that if he
owned all of his flaws and he said "I'm short and
I'm white and I'm blah blah blah blah." Right he
says all these things about them the other person
has nothing left to say he pulls all the wind out
of their sales he pulls all the punches because
he punches himself with that and then they have
nothing left and so basically we want to address
all of the concerns they have upfront in our
damaging admissions and so what happens is the
the the linguistic power of this is that you have
statement but other statement and the statement
that comes after the word but is the part that is
the thing you want them to believe and so you say
something that is true and believable and damaging
to you so that they can believe that thing that
comes after but so let me show you how this works
so if I said "Hey these markers smell like [__]
but they write four times longer than other
markers and they don't dry out." You're going
to be like "Wow I now believe that more than
if I just said these markers last four times
longer than other markers before they dry out." If
I said they smell terrible and or but they do that
it's more persuasive now watch this let's flip it
these markers write four times longer than others
but they smell like crap what am I emphasizing i'm
actually emphasizing the fact that they smell bad
not the fact that they write longer and so we
use the first part to gain trust for the second
half of the statement viagra only works for 4
to 6 hours but you're going to have the time
of your life right and so it might raise your
your blood pressure but you're going to have an
amazing night right our websites are ugly as hell
but they convert right our systems are incredibly
boring but they work right if I said our systems
work but they're incredibly boring I'm going to
emphasize on the boring part not on the fact that
they work and so by how you organize your language
around words like but which are amplifiers it
allows you to say damaging admissions in a way
that's compelling and so right now what I would
like you to do is write down all of the flaws all
the things that people complain about the things
that you know you could do better and claim them
because the thing is that the prospect is already
thinking them but if you can claim them instead
of them thinking them you acknowledge them gain
trust and then when you make your statements they
will believe you more so if you want to stand
out in a crowded marketplace tell the truth it
makes you more authentic and if you can do with
humor you get even more bonus points so it's like
listen our gym has honestly pretty terrible
parking our AC is kind of on and off i don't
have the best equipment but our sessions are more
fun than everyone else's cuz it's all we've got
if I said that you now believe me right the thing
is is if you saw an ad that said that you'd be
like I kind of believe this guy he's probably
not so bad right he's telling the truth and I'll
bet you his classes probably are fun now if I just
said "We have the most fun sessions." You wouldn't
believe me because anyone can say that but what
people won't say is the truth so number six show
don't tell now this one is one of those ones that
you will probably nod your head on and be like
"Yes of course show don't tell." But the thing
is is when I say show don't tell I'm actually
talking more about breaking down the reasoning
so kind of like I was alluding to earlier which
is instead of saying get more sales describe what
the experience of getting more sales means or what
that moment would look like like selling somebody
that you're running out of order forms because
customers are reading their credit cards to you
over the phone too fast that is the experience of
getting more sales right so you want to note the
descriptions of what's happening and the emotions
they might experience the overwhelm of having
too many phones ring and not enough salespeople
that's the experience of getting advertising that
works don't just say get more leads describe the
experience of what getting more leads means
that's what they want to experience they want
to see their gym full they want to know what it's
like to have a line around the corner they want
to know what it's like where they actually have
to reorganize their gym so that they can actually
make room for more people at the session those
are the good problems that we would describe
which also yes they're problems but if we describe
the future problems they would prefer to have than
their current problems those are arguably some
of the most compelling things you can include
in copy because if you can describe the problems
they haven't thought about yet then it's likely
that you've experienced them or help other people
experience them which then increase the likelihood
that they believe it will happen for them and so
the big thing here in terms of show don't tell
obviously from a creative perspective you want the
videos to demonstrate it you want your creative
your images to demonstrate it but your actual copy
itself you want to use more descriptive language
that is specific to the experience they're going
to have the moments and I'm going to repeat this
theme because it's big what is the moment that
someone's going to experience that they got more
sales what does that moment feel like what does it
look like when what moment will they realize that
this has actually occurred show me that sales has
occurred describe to me that scenario that is how
you write exceptional copy and what's cool about
this is if you want to write unique copy the way
you describe that moment will always be unique
to you compared to other people and so you can
always have fresh copy that sounds different and
interesting because you're not just going to use
the same words everyone uses number seven tie
benefits to status whenever possible so a lot
of people talk about benefits not features which
is true but I like to take this a step further
mentally which is a cookbook so fast and easy that
all your friends will wonder how you found the
time to be fit and cook for your family right that
would be okay that's one level right of benefit
but the idea is what is the like in that benefit
what we tied in is we tied in their friends their
friends are going to give them status because
of this thing which is just a cookbook right so
rather than say "Hey you're going to cook meals
fast and easy." Sure that might be an element of
it right but so fast that their friends are going
to wonder how they're doing it is another level of
this and so whenever we can tie status and this is
why in the in the lead's book I talk about this on
page 140 i talk about the what who when framework
this is where this becomes incredibly important
and so what we want to do when we're thinking
about status and the reason that this framework
works so well is that we're thinking about the who
right obviously it's them but who is giving them
the status because their status within different
realms is it their family who's giving them status
is it their friends is it their colleagues
or co-workers is it their rivals is it their
competitors who are they who are they vanquishing
and so humans are a competitive species we do
desire status because it increases the likelihood
that we're able to procreate and create more kids
and acquire resources right and so we want to tie
all of our benefits to what it's going to do what
they ultimately want which is going to be status
now what's interesting is that the status that
people get is going to be unique to that person
within their subgroup so if I'm going to try
to describe status to a mother it's going to be
probably from kids that excel and other parents
wonder how they're parenting not from getting a
Lamborghini right now if I'm trying to talk to
a hustle bro who's 20 years old then probably
talking about a Lamborghini might convert now
it might not convert the type of hustle bro that
I would be looking for but nonetheless it would
convert some person who's interested in that right
i'm all about mosy mobiles and having cash cars
that you can buy for seven grand and then not have
to worry about car payment so you can actually
rich in your bank account rather than in other
people's eyes but point being if we're writing
copy we have to meet them where they're at and so
the the wording that we think about this and also
just to give you more color on this is that we
think past present future so how am I going to
create status for them with their spouse them with
their wife today and in the future and in the past
so now I have multiple different people who are
giving and awarding status to this person through
the copy we're writing and different time periods
so it gives you endless variations and angles to
approach the benefits all right and so you want
to think the lines so that you can or so that your
friend's mouths will drop with envy right that's
what we're trying to describe here number eight is
that we want to use urgency and scarcity all right
now to be clear urgency and scarcity people lock
them together but they're actually different
things all right so scarcity is a function of
quantity urgency is a function of time all right
so that means that I have an unlimited amount
of widgets that I'm trying to sell but I'm only
running my promotion until midnight it's a it's
a function of time that's urgency if I only have
a hundred widgets or I'm only choosing to sell 100
spots which scarcity you can choose to have then
at that point once a 100 spots maybe that takes a
year to sell or maybe it takes 5 seconds to sell
that line in the sand no matter how many people
want to buy it after that point cannot buy it
now you can have both but fundamentally all we're
trying to do is show that other people want it and
that they have to act quickly what we're trying to
do is decrease the action threshold threshold so
they take action and the key to making urgency
and scarcity work is making it legitimate there's
actually I don't even know if there's really much
more to it than actually having it be legitimate
there's there's really not another secret now
there's different types of urgency and scarcity
which I talk about in the offers books so I have
a whole chapter uh in the offers books so page
104 for scarcity and then the next chapter right
afterwards I have for urgency which is uh page
112 and so I talk about four different types of
urgency and different things that you can do to
include scarcity um in your offerings whether
it's products or services but no matter what
you just needed to be real that's all I can
tell you and the part that people struggle with
is they're like but what if someone wants to buy
after midnight what if someone wants to buy when I
already said I have 100 spots it means you say no
and you say no so you can maintain the reputation
so that the next time you have scarcity guess who
the first buyer is going to be the one who wasn't
able to buy the last time so you're digging your
well before you're thirsty i would always prefer
to underell my demand so I always have more later
otherwise you're always going to be looking for
the next kill the next sale and you're going to
be putting the scarcity urgency up but everyone
knows it doesn't matter because you're not going
to sell out and that's where you start losing
power now number nine is implied authority all
right now this isn't this is a nasty one in a cool
way so this actually goes back to number one so if
you're the only double secret black belt in the
area say it right if you've transformed over you
know a thousand people to black belts say so if
you're the only you know if you have a pro alete
client and they allow you to say it say it all of
these things imply authority and people listen to
and trust authority figures more and so that's
how we've helped 5,000 gyms or 6,000 gyms over
the last seven years and so part of authority
is also just longevity if you say we've been in
business for 40 years the likelihood that you are
a legitimate business is pretty high right that's
actually a pretty rare feat so if you've been in
business for a while that's a big thing now maybe
that you and your co-founders in aggregate have
done over 20 years of advertising maybe it's four
of you guys have all done five years but it sounds
better to say in aggregate we've done over 20
years of advertising right now again the the key
here is if you have something as a hook like as
seen on Oprah's best boot camps or best boot camp
in Vegas or best chiropractor in Vegas or best
whatever is this is why these tiny little awards
matter so much because you can actually even start
a sales conversation with did you find us on the
Vegas best boot camps list now you might know that
no one even knows that this list exists and that's
okay because that list just gives you applied
authority when you actually have the conversation
with a prospect and so at the end of the day this
is where proof does beat promise all right and so
we're now getting into the believability of the
claim right so this is why it's further down on
here because someone has to want the thing that
you're offering first once they offer it then all
their their warning bells are going to go off like
"Why should I believe this person?" And that's
where you want to have the proof that yes they
can believe you and this is why documenting and
substantiating the things that you have done and
the people that you have helped ultimately makes
you more likely to be persuasive right if you have
a thousand people who have you know you have a
thousand testimonials versus somebody or a thou
imagine you go to a you see you looking between
two restaurants on Yelp right one has a fivestar
with three reviews that's three there you go three
reviews right or you've got 3,000 reviews why not
let's just stick with it all right but you've
got a 4.6 which one are you going for for sure
no question you're going to the one that has 4,000
reviews now it's 4,000 uh with a 4.6 rating rather
than a five but that doesn't make sense this one
has five this is a 4.6 the proof demonstrates the
implied authority that obviously these people
have been around they know what they're doing
they service a lot of customers it's social proof
all right now number 10 always have a PS statement
all right now why do we have a PS statement so
it's a power sentence which is what I like to
think about it all right is that power sentence
the the two most red parts of advertising number
one the headline number two the PS statement
and so if you have the two most red lines in
all of your advertising you better be sure you're
thinking about what you're writing and at the very
least have a PS statement right and so always
have them and make sure that they're strong and
so I have a number of different strategies that I
use for PS statements and I'll tell you probably
my top three all right so number one in emails
I prefer to have some sort of sign off that gets
people jazzed they're very excited to have I want
to reward them for having read my email so this
is where I put jokes in this is where I put fun
stuff that's light so that every once in a while
when I do want to put a call to action I make this
PS a call to action that's strong because I know
everyone's going to read it and click it because
I've train them to click that link all right now
in an advertising setting that PS statement is
either going to be a disclaimer of who this is not
for which often works really really well hey by
the way if you're just getting started this isn't
for you this is only for people doing X Y and Z
click here that's very strong as a PS statement
another PS statement that works very well is just
recapping everything in one sentence we've helped
a thousand people we're good at making black
belts if you're serious about black belts click
here boom right and so it's like hey if you did
if you just read to the bottom and skip to the
bottom like I do this is the main this is the main
nuggets right your main points of persuasion all
in one place now you can also piggyback on this
with a PPS statement and have two PS statements
because guess what the only thing that's read uh
less than or sorry the only thing that's read more
than the normal copy but less than the headline
and the PS is the PPS that's the third most
read statement in copy so I would also include
something there too if you need it now number 11
this one's going to be this one this is like it's
amazing how effective this is and also how simple
it is and the only thing simpler is to not do it
so you have to have clear CTA so calls to action
if you do not tell someone exactly what to do next
you decrease the likelihood that they do it so you
want it to be stupid simple not you know what to
do you know you know you have to they don't know
right and so if you want X click the button and on
the next page fill your information then select a
convenient time for you to come in so that you
won't miss right we want to be very clear about
what they have to do and what's going to happen
next right they're not going to guess but here's
a really really cool sub point about this if you
tell someone to take an option or take a step and
then you tell them what's going to happen next
and then what you said is going to happen happens
you increase your sad do correspondence meaning
you gain influence over them because what you
said after they followed your instruction came
true it's the reason Martha Stewart was such a
powerful influencer compared to other people she
literally gave people recipes to follow and she
said "If you want to bake a cake here's the 18
steps for baking a cake." And when you follow
these 18 steps you get a cake and then when you
get a cake and the cake the cake tastes good and
then you tied to status because other people say
"This cake is amazing and your family loves you
for baking this cake." Guess what happens she
gains influence over you because the next time
she gives you instructions you are more likely to
follow them and so we can embed this within the
process of persuasion so we want to basically
make promises keep promises make promises keep
promises make promises keep promises over and
over and over again where they actually take
action and that's the key part is that they have
to take action on something you said and what
you have to say will happen happens that's what
makes it it's not just saying "Oh open loop oh
just make promises." They have to take action
and then your promise gets fulfilled based on
their action so outline step one two three and
outline what's going to happen next because when
it does they'll believe you the next time you
tell them to do something and like I believe in
this so much the reason I called my whole company
acquisition.com was so that the name of my company
was the call to action so if someone's like "Hey
how do I find out more about acquisition.com?" I
had someone show up in my building and say "Hey
how do I apply to acquisition.com?" And I was
like number 12 and this is a this is a this is so
good this is so good i mean all of these are good
this is why I use these like I've really tried to
8020 this for you guys third grade reading level
most copy doesn't convert because people have
to pause to understand it and the moment they
pause they stop because it takes more horsepower
than they're willing to dedicate to it so we have
to assume that the prospect is in a rush doesn't
care about what you have has below a third grade
reading level and is distracted and that's the
person we have to grab by the throat and bring
into our world this is the $100 million scaling
road map and what we did was we broke down the
10 stages of scaling and so if you're advertising
whether that be in emails for outreach or writing
phone scripts or video sales letters or web
pages or making content all of these things
are messaging that include copy to get people
to do stuff and so what we did was we broke
down all the different stages of scaling into
these 10 steps where you get stuck and how to
break through and it's all absolutely free and
so if you're a business owner you're not sure
where you're at enter your business information
it's acquisition.com/roadmap and then on the
thank you page if you'd like us to help you
with your marketing if you'd like us to help
you scale then I'd love to have you come out to
one of our workshops we run them monthly here at
our headquarters in Vegas so on the thank you
page you can book a call but otherwise this
is absolutely free you don't need to attend a
call or anything like that to get this it's my
gift to you so go acquisition.com/roadmap and
enjoy the rest of the video sentences that are
too complex or use too big of words you're not
writing a college paper right you're writing
an ad that has milliseconds to catch someone's
attention so make the process as frictionless
as possible so if you want to make easy copy you
want to make light copy the way that you do that
is you look at everything that makes copy hard
to understand you're writing hard to understand
and remove it so great copy the words fade into
the background no one's actually thinking about
the words they're just understanding what it
says and then ultimately being more likely to
be persuaded by it so if I have something that's
written at ninth grade reading level but or third
grade reading level so many people cannot rate at
a n read at a nth grade reading level many people
can read but they can't read at that level and so
if we want to automatically disqualify twothirds
of the people who read the copy keep it at
nth grade but if you want everyone who can
read to read then keep it at third grade
look at the most popular books in America
they are purposely written because the authors
know what they're doing at a level that most
people can understand so fancy equals friction
simple equals sales i put every ad that I write
through free reading level tool and I continue
to edit the copy as if it is third grade reading
level now I'll give you a couple quick tips on
this all right so number one is you want short
sentences small words big promises right big
proof you want few adverbs and better verbs
meaning instead of he quickly ran say he sprinted
and so we want word concision we want to have as
few words as possible to communicate the point
but we want to keep the words themselves as simple
as possible now if you're like wait a second
sprinting versus running fast sprinting is a
more advanced word and this is why writing copy is
difficult we have to think is there another word
that people also understand that I don't have
to use two words and I can use one now at the
highest levels I will never prioritize concision
over simplicity so simplicity trumps concision
meaning fewer words concision itself is like a
nth grade word all right um which is using fewer
words to say the same thing as many words but you
probably understood it better that's what's crazy
is this stuff actually works all right and
so these are 12 but you know I do like overd
delivering so I'm going to give you one more bonus
lucky number 13 all right so instead of 13 because
that might be uh that might be unlucky so we'll
put bonus here i don't believe in superstition
but let's just roll with it is whenever possible
use humor all right because uh if you look at the
Old Spice ad the highest converting ad of all time
to my knowledge um in terms of it took something
was a not a market leader and make it the made it
the the market share uh you know dominator is it
was funny right and the thing is is that if you
can entertain and educate at the same time you
win right because entertainment makes something
significantly broader education is what's going
to change someone's behavior and so we want our
ads to both entertain and educate entertainment
to go broad education to go deep the education
changes the behavior meaning that they take the
click that means that they do what you want them
to do this is why now if I had to pick one thing
to cut out it would be humor all right because the
you can make ads that convert with the other 12
but if you want the extra sauce right tickets to
that thing you've always wanted to go to right if
you want that extra sizzle then you can add humor
in the difficulty is how do you make something
funny for everyone and this is where testing is
so important right if you look at how comedians
I'm a big study of comedy because I really enjoy
it um how come comedians make their whole specials
is that they will go to many many clubs test
new material and they might find when they do a
60-minute set that there's only eight minutes that
people really liked they then frontload the first
eight minutes their next set and then they have
52 minutes of other stuff and they find two more
minutes that people like and they put it there
at the front for the next one now they've got
10 minutes and that's how they build their sets
until the whole 60 minutes is hilarious because
they've tested it in North Carolina and New York
and Mexico and internationally and so they've got
something that just converts and by converts
it means it gets people to do what they want
them to do which in the context of comedy is
laughing right and so if we can make something
that's both funny and educational ultimately we
win and if you like this then I have 13 years
of business insights that I've learned uh and
I think you'll absolutely love that video and